so what do you got for me oh man let's
get right into this right uh coming from
uh google plus this is marcos
d831
marcos d8 that's his code name that's
his code name yeah
so uh what do you think of computer
generated all right examples genetic
algorithm based images music etc
yeah i i'm cool with it yeah
really really in fact when it first came
out it was striking you know because it
was different and it had a different
kind of sound
but
personally
i think
that the computer doesn't yet
know how to feel emotion
yes and what is art
emotion that's my line i say that
cleanly please i'm sorry what is art
without emotion okay now you can butt in
uh
yeah so
so i mean think about it
you know i love me some some um escher
all right uh the first emcee
mch m c escher yeah
i don't even think i'm familiar with m.c
escher
you didn't hear him at the club the
other night yeah
so so the artist m.c escher his drawings
are like perfect illustrations of
geometric forms basically okay and so
they're fun to look at they're fun to
get lost in
but at the end of the day you don't take
emotional ownership of it right and i
think the greatest art allows you to
walk up to it
and say
that means something to me regardless of
what the artist thought or felt
and then it's a communion between you
and the creative energies of the artist
if it's a computer just punching out
notes according to some algorithm
i don't know that it can reach those
same heights
but now
so maybe we need the computer
that like can cop an attitude
and then if it composes music while it's
under uh disturbed mental states you
need a computer that can have a broken
heart
you need a computer to get dumped by a
girl a computer that that means the
computer's a guy excuse me don't you
know that all computers that announce
the end of the world are female
well wouldn't they though
seriously
there is two minutes left before it's
self-destruction that's true yeah it's
all like yo get the hell out and see
that's why they don't make it a man's
voice because they would actually add
some urgency to it you know what i mean
self-destruct in ten seconds right yeah
the world will ahead what they should
have is a brother a real brother just
like yo man you're gonna die
get the hell out of here what's your
problem
are you crazy you're still here
that'll get out of work that's good
that'll be the
the brother computer another computer
oh damn man you did so i think for if a
computer were to compose the blues it
would need to know sadness right and i'd
sim i just don't know how that maybe
that they will come you can program that
in but right now no so yes i i i'm happy
to call it art but it's not the highest
levels of art that members of our own
species have achieved so computers can
make art it's just art that sucks okay
exactly i'll accept that i'll accept
that all right okay let's move on